la première résolution que nous
souhaitons aborder concerne le texte
relatif au cadre financier pluriannuel
elle a été présentée par mon
prédécesseur jean bizet et notre ancien
collègue simon sutour qui lui même a été
président de cette commission en juin
2020 juste après la publication par la
commission européenne de sa nouvelle
proposition de cadre financier qui
doublait quasiment la mise et proposer
un instrument de relance de 750
milliards d'euros financé par un emprunt
commun pour répondre à la pandémie
nous en avons débattu en séance la
semaine dernière le sénat a ainsi marqué
son soutien de principe à cette réponse
d'inspiration franco allemande tout en
s'inquiétant de son financement le
conseil européen du 21 juillet 2020 a
validé cette architecture globale et
s'est accordé sur les grandes lignes du
budget et du plan de relance
je ne reviendrai pas sur les inévitables
compromis qu'a appliqué la négociation
même si nous regrettons amèrement que
les rabais n'ait pu être supprimé mais
je sais que vous le regrettez aussi mon
collègue patrice joly qui a désormais
rapporter avec moi sur ce sujet vous
interrogera certainement pour ma part je
souhaite simplement vous demandez
comment le gouvernement entend se
positionner dans la négociation en cours
sur l'attribution du fonds de réserve
désistement du break site
cette ligne de 5 milliards d'euros est
destinée à compenser les effets du bric
site nous venons de l'avoir en
commission subsidiarité à l'instant je
sais qu'elle est soumise au débat
actuellement beaucoup s'inquiètent
beaucoup vont vouloir aussi aller
chercher leur part du gâteau et je sais
que le sujet n'est pas épuisé la
deuxième résolution européenne que nous
souhaitons évoqué est relative à la
réforme de la politique agricole commune
sur ce sujet le sénat a adopté trois
résolutions européenne depuis que la
commission a publié en 2018 sa
proposition la dernière de ces
résolutions datant de juin 2020 la
négociation a depuis bien avant celle
enveloppe financière a été arrêtée les
ministres de l'agriculture ont trouvé un
accord en 2020 sur les orientations de
la prochaine réforme et le parlement
européen a adopté dans la foulée les
trois projets de règlements largement
amendé ouvrant la voie aux négociations
en trilogue pourtant nous restons sur
notre faim
de nombreuses interrogations et ambigu
et demeure à ce stade en particulier sur
l'articulation entre la future pac 2021
et 2027 et la transition ouverte ce
qu'on appelle le green deal
nous attendons toujours que la
commission européenne publie les études
d'impact des stratégies biodiversité et
de la ferme à la table
nous savons que le ministère de
l'agriculture des états unis estiment
leur impact à une réduction de 12% de la
production agricole de l'union
européenne à l'horizon 2030
que deviendrait dans un tel contexte
l'objectif de souveraineté alimentaire
tant défendu actuellement monsieur le
ministre nos résolutions dont elle pas
suffisamment alerté le gouvernement sur
ce point vous nous dire troisième
résolution que je vous propose d'évoquer
en première partie celle sur la mobile
la modernisation de la politique
européenne de la concurrence sur ce
sujet le sénat a adopté une résolution
ambitieuse en juillet 2020 est fondée
sur le rapport d'information très
documenté de nos collègues alain
chatillon et olivier henno au nom du
groupe de travail stratégie industrielle
le sénat a appelé à une réforme
d'ampleur de la politique européenne de
la concurrence
la large consultation ouverte par la
commission européenne sur ce sujet nous
avait donné l'espoir qu'une évolution
profonde pouvait s'envisager
depuis nous assistons à quelques
avancées des assouplissements dans la
mise en application des règles
européennes de concurrence ou des
innovations plus substantiel mais limité
mais limitée au seul champ dit numérique
nous croyons toutefois une véritable
modernisation d'ensemble de la politique
de concurrence y compris ex ante et
n'interviennent finalement jamais nous
savons combien cet exercice est
difficile car ils exigeraient
l'unanimité des états membres
pouvez vous me dire s'il est toujours à
l'agenda et si la france reste mobilisés
en ces sens bon programme seul ministre
et je vous sais de la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs comme vous
l'avez dit c'est un exercice je crois
rituel pour la commission est important
et qui en même temps pour ce qui me
concerne le premier donc je le découvre
avec vous mais je suis très heureux de
t'avoir cette occasion de revenir
peut-être de manière un peu plus posé
approfondie sur un certain nombre de
sujets qui font l'objet de résultats
récents ou de négociations en cours vous
les avez évoqué pour les trois
résolutions les trois thèmes afférents
et je vais essayer de vous en donner
l'état le plus précis possible vous avez
donc sélectionné ces trois résolutions
je crois que nous en verrons ensuite
plusieurs autres sept thèmes au total
avec un intérêt particulier dans ma
réponse est je crois dans votre question
pour le paquet budgétaire puisque lui
même et si je puis dire à tiroirs et
comprend un certain nombre de références
aux autre sujet qui nous occupe et que
nous discuterons soit maintenant soit un
peu plus tard dans la matinée à la
question de la politique agricole
commune celle de la défense et d'autres
thématiques qui sont aussi des enjeux
budgétaires
vous avez adopté vous le rappeliez
monsieur le président de résolution
européenne sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel 2021 et 2027 et sur le plan
de relance européen en janvier et en
juillet 2020 et je rends d'ailleurs
hommage au travail du président bizet du
sénateur sutour qui les avait à l'époque
porté comme vous le rappeliez alors
s'agissant de cette nouvelle période
budgétaire européenne qui a depuis
commencé le 1er janvier dernier nous
avons eu l'occasion d'en parler à
l'occasion du débat sur les ressources
propres
nous avons été je crois particulièrement
mobiliser collectivement pour défendre
pendant plus de deux années de
négociations puisque le paquet
budgétaire était présenté en mai 2018
par la commission un grand nombre des
priorités que vous avez soutenu que vous
avez définies dans ses résolutions
notamment dans la première
et puis face à la pandémie et à ses
conséquences qui n'était évidemment non
anticipé non anticipable au moment de la
proposition de la commission européenne
comme vous
vais rappeler un plan de relance a été
bâtie progressivement par l'initiative
franco-allemande du 18 mai 2020 puis par
l'accord politique des 27 chefs d'état
et de gouvernement le 21 juillet dernier
et c'est là dessus en anticipation de ce
conseil notamment que vous aviez
souligné les positions du sénat quant à
la relance européenne
alors à quoi dont abou dis pour en
dresser un panorama rapide mais aussi
précis que possible à l'issue de sept
accords du 21 juillet du conseil
européen de plusieurs jours comme vous
vous en souvenez et de la négociation
avec le parlement européen cet automne
l'union européenne s'est dotée d'un plan
de relance européen et d'un budget
européen pour la période 2021 et 2027
qui représentent ensemble 1824 milliards
d'euros exactement soit près de 2 % 1 8%
du revenu national brut de la richesse
produite par l'union européenne ce qui
est un niveau historique je le rappelle
si nous combinons l'effet sur la période
pertinente c'est à dire les trois
prochaines années
2021 2022 2023 puisque le plan de
relance lui qui est un plan d'urgence
sera déboursé sur la première partie du
cadre budgétaire
sur ces trois années cet effort combiné
représente un doublement du budget
ordinaire de l'union européenne si on le
compare à la période précédente
en niveau annuel donc c'est un effort
européen nécessaire face à la crise que
nous connaissons mais dont je veux
rappeler aussi le caractère très
ambitieux et très significatif et je
crois que cela correspond aux priorités
que vous portiez sans être totalement
exhaustive voulait insister sur quelques
grands points la tension qui émergeait
dans les résolutions concernant le
budget pluriannuel plus spécifiquement
vous aviez à coeur dans ses résolutions
du sénat que les nouvelles priorités de
l'union ne remplace pas les politiques
je n'aime pas tellement l'expression
mais dites traditionnelles certains
utilisant le mode traditionnel pour
évacuer ses priorités progressivement
c'est évidemment pas la position que le
gouvernement français sous votre
impulsion et recommandations a suivi
d'abord la politique agricole commune
je rappelle première politique de
l'union européenne par son montant par
la chronologie et l'ambition historique
que nous portons depuis maintenant
cinquante huit ans autour de cette
première politique intégrée de l'union
cela suffirait à en rappeler toute
l'importance elle était attaquée dans la
proposition initiale de la commission
européenne comme vous le savez en mai
2018 avec selon les façons dont on
calcule mais une baisse d'environ 15
milliards d'euros en euros courants
donc c'était d'un montant très
significatif par rapport à la période
budgétaire précédente 2014 2020 c'est
une position que nous n'avions pas plus
le sénat est d'ailleurs l'assemblée
nationale que le gouvernement a accepté
et nous avons donc combattu pour relever
le niveau d'ambition et de financement
de la politique agricole commune
je crois que les résultats obtenus
traduisent cette priorité atteignent cet
objectif puisque au total nous avons
même légèrement augmenté le
l'enveloppent total en euros courants
consacrer la politique agricole commune
sur les sept prochaines années
plus de 385 milliards d'euros comparé à
3 181 milliards d'euros d'exécution
budgétaire sur la période précédente
si l'on additionne les forts central du
budget 2021 et 2027 et un complément sur
le 2e pilier qui a été négocié et
apporté par le plan de relance européen
et sur les paiements directs
le premier pilier qui est
particulièrement important
comme vous le savez pour nos
agriculteurs c'est une stabilisation des
revenus via ses paiements directs que
nous avons assuré pour les sept
prochaines années c'est un combat
centrale
le premier dans notre action budgétaire
mené par la france tout au long de ces
deux années de négociations
je crois que nous avons là
collectivement par cette mobilisation
obtenu un résultat important nécessaire
est satisfaisant même si j'y reviendrai
dans un instant la réforme de la
politique agricole commune ne se résume
pas à la question et de son enveloppe
budgétaire
je tiens aussi à souligner quelques
autres priorités qui étaient mentionnés
dans les réseaux
sûr de votre assemblée sur la politique
de cohésion qui a également augmenté
pour les régions françaises notamment
les régions l'outre-mer je pense aussi
au fonds européen de défense qui s'il
n'a pas atteint le niveau d'ambition que
nous aurions souhaité a été créé tout
simplement et est doté de 8 milliards
d'euros sur la période 2021 et 2027
je pense au programme iter si important
pour l'énergie la recherche sur
l'énergie nucléaire d'avenir qui a été
augmenté également pas tout à fait
autant que nous l'aurions souhaité je le
reconnais mais par rapport à la période
précédente et un fonds dédié aux
questions de santé qui face à la
pandémie que nous connaissons montre
plus encore qu'auparavant sa pertinence
et qui était créée pour un montant total
de 5 milliards d'euros montant qui
permet notamment de compléter les
financements européens d'acquisition des
vaccins
donc cela devient opérationnel
rapidement et extrêmement concret de
manière concomitante adoption de ce
budget je le disais genre dit un mot il
y a le plan de relance 750 milliards
d'euros au total 390 milliards d'euros
de subventions budgétaires 360 milliards
d'euros de prêts sur le montant de
subventions budgétaires qui est prévu
les 390 milliards que je mentionnais
vous le savez c'est un peu plus de 40
milliards d'euros probablement plus
exactement pour le 45 milliards d'euros
qui seront destinés à la france via
l'état ou via les régions selon les
enveloppes
si je suis un tout petit peu plus
détaillé sur ce plan de relance est une
autre façon de le présenter et de
retrouver ses 750 milliards d'euros nous
avons un instrument central qui est
l'aide à la relance dans les états
membres pour un montant de 672 points 5
milliards d'euros un homme une
augmentation temporaire des fonds de
cohésion complèment compléter aussi par
le plan de relance pour près de 50
milliards d'euros 47 5 très précisément
jusqu'en 2023 et
un renforcement je l'évoquais sa valeur
totale de la pac du 2e pilier du feader
pour 7,5 milliards d'euros 1,6 c'est
important parce que dix départements
français en bénéficieront directement
qu'un fonds de transition juste en
matière écologique qui sera complétée de
17,5 milliards d'euros un programme de
soutien à l'investissement privé
c'est la suite de ce qu'on avait appelé
le plan juncker et puis dans ce plan de
relance pour finir un renforcement de
quelques actions qui sont devenues clef
en période de crise le renforcement du
programme de recherche horizon europe et
le renforcement d'un programme de
protection civile ce qui complète les
actions sanitaires mentionné notamment
permettant l'achat de respirateurs de
masques de d'équipements médicaux qui
forment une réserve d'urgence qui avait
été une ancienne proposition de michel
barnier compléter sur le volet sanitaire
grâce à ce plan de relance
s'agissant des ressources que vous
évoquez aussi dans les résolutions
l'accord européen vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président n'a pas permis de
réaliser l'ambition commune du sénat et
du gouvernement de baisser d'une part le
taux de perception des droits de douane
qui sont une forme disons le de rabais
cacher pour certains pays notamment la
belgique et les pays bas
pardon et on les augmente en plus alors
par rapport à la période actuelle et
nous n'avons pas réussi à mettre un
terme au rabais tout court pour cinq
pays comme nous l'avons amplement
discuté je le regrette je le dis aussi
avec conviction je crois que nous avons
mené un combat je sais que nous avons
mené ensemble un combat gagnant
essentiels qui je lui en suis convaincu
marquera l'europe durablement au-delà de
cette crise c'est la dette commune c'est
la capacité de relance européenne cela a
été même si les choses sont sans doute
un peu plus complexe mais une forme de
contrepartie le maintien des rabais n'a
pas été le combat gagnant de cette fois
ci mais je crois qu'il peut l'être la
prochaine fois parce que nous aurons le
débat sur les ressources propres et que
cela nous donne aussi une occasion de
remettre en cause l'ensemble du système
de financement et de ces aberrations
dont font partie des rabais pour les
années suivantes
après 2027 mais ça se prépare très en
amont comme vous le savez mieux que moi
et donc dès aujourd'hui ce cadre
financier pluriannuel et cette décision
sur les ressources propres ont néanmoins
introduit symboliquement une première
étape c'est la contribution sur les
emballages plastiques dès 2021 que nous
savons qu'elle n'est pas véritablement
une ressource propre plutôt une forme de
bonus malus mais son caractère
symbolique est important et surtout
cette feuille de route que nous
évoquions semble la semaine dernière
négociée entre les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui je le rappelle est
actée à 27 c dans l'accord du 21 juillet
et a été renforcée précisé par la
négociation avec le parlement européen
avec une obligation pour la commission
s'acquittera dans les prochaines
semaines de présenter des actes lice
latif européen dès ce semestre donc dès
le premier semestre 2011 21 sur deux de
ses ressources qui sont à mon sens les
ressources clés sur le plan politique et
budgétaire
le mécanisme d'ajustement carbone à nos
frontières et la taxe sur les services
numériques laquelle vous faisiez
référence à propos de la régulation du
numérique et l'engagement qui a été pris
conjointement par les polices la terre
européen le conseil et le parlement
européen c'est d'aboutir d'ici fin 2022
donc c'est un combat d'aujourd'hui et
d'urgence sur ces deux ressources
propres pour qu'elle entre en vigueur
dès le 1er janvier 2023 est certain je
le dis avec honnêteté pas encore est ce
possible je crois très profondément nous
n'avons jamais été aussi proches depuis
40 ans puisque aucune ressource propre
net et créé depuis les années soixante
dix plus de quarante ans de créer de
nouvelles ressources propres
essentielles qui sont d'autant plus
importantes qu'elles ne sont pas
magiques mais elles sont juste parce
qu'elles font payer des contributeurs
qui aujourd'hui n'apporte rien aux
actions publiques politiques publiques
européennes que nous menons et
contribuer bénéficie pardon largement de
notre marché unique je pense bien sûr
les entreprises non européennes dans le
secteur du numérique ou qui exportent
des produits qui ne respectent pas
encore nos toutes nos exigences
environnementales
par le prix du carbone dont elle
bénéficie donc ces deux ressources sont
clés à tous égards dans les priorités
politiques européennes et le futur
remboursement du plan de relance
et cette audition est l'occasion pour
moi de vous remercier monsieur le
président et l'ensemble de l'assemblée
de votre commission en particulier pour
le large soutien que je sais exigeant et
vigilant le large soutien du sénat au
projet de loi autorisant la ratification
la décision ressources propres c'était
jeudi dernier et d avant-hier la
promulgation de cette décision a été
faite par le gouvernement au journal
officiel et nous avons transmis lierre
pour être très précis
l'instrument de ratification aux
autorités européennes pour que la france
soit donc l'un des premiers états
membres le cinquième a assuré la
ratification de cette décision sur les
ressources propres à la suite de cette
étape parlementaire essentiel nous
finalisons notre plan de relance
national car il doit vous le savez aussi
être notifiée formellement au plan
européen et nous associons d'ailleurs à
ce travail via le secrétariat général
des affaires européennes est en lien
avec la ministre jacqueline gourault les
collectivités territoriales autorités de
gestion des fonds européens pour définir
précisément les lignes directrices de ce
plan et j'espère devant vous je le dis
c'est le combat là aussi que nous
engageons que concrètement de manière
sonnante et trébuchante les fonds
européens du plan de relance arriveront
dès le mois de mai en france et dans les
autres pays européens ça n'est pas
encore acquis car nous devons assurer
que les 40 parlements nationaux
concernés dans les 27 états membres
assurent la ratification vous le savez
c'est un processus qui prend d'habitude
deux ans au moins et qui doit être
assurée désormais en cinq mois c'est
long c'est très court par rapport à
d'habitude c'est sans doute loin par
rapport à nos besoins de relance mais
nous pouvons le faire et avoir un
préfinancement je vous interromps 12
secondes
mini sur ce sujet puisque vous parlez
effectivement de l'arrivée des fonds
potentiellement levés ge nous avait dit
joint vous vous espérez mai mais on
avait un petit un petit bip puisque le
sjm nous avait dit que globalement
c'était 13% dans le lobe qui étaient
distribués on prêt en prépaiement et que
c'est 13% en fait servaient à rembourser
déjà des avances qui aurait été faite
par l'état sur le sur le plan de relance
si vous vraiment trois minutes vous
pouvez nous en dire est sûre ça
clarifierait les échanges qu'on a eue
avec lui en fallait trois choses là
dessus les 13% de nous parlons c'est le
préfinancement qui al'avantage de
pouvoir être décaissés dès que la
ratification par les 27 est fait
la commission a besoin pour aller sur
les marchés emprunter l'argent
nécessaire au plan de relance que les 27
aient fini de ratification elle le
prépare en temps masqué si je puis dire
mais l'acte le financement ne peut le
faire qu'après cette ratification c'est
ça que j'espère au moins de même un
scénario un peu moins optimiste au mois
de juin mais battons nous pour le faire
le plus vite possible
et dès l'instant où cela est prêt même
si tous les plans de relance nationaux
n'ont pas été validés elle peut assurer
le préfinancement ces fameux 13 % de
l'enveloppé totale des 750 milliards et
notamment les 390 milliards de
subventions donc pour la france ça
représente un montant d'environ 5
milliards d'euros cet argent la
commission ne si je puis dire ne
l'affectent pas elle le verse aux
autorités nationales en fonction des
enveloppes auxquelles je crois
si comme nous l'avons fait nous avons
démarré le plan de relance avant ça
vient oui d'une certaine façon en
remboursement s'est pas construit comme
ça mais de fait nous aurons dépensé plus
de 5 milliards d'euros du plan de
relance national dans son ensemble d'ici
le mois de juin
nous avons déjà des pâtés pensée 11
milliards d'euros donc
non c'est pas poste-à-poste si je puis
dire c'est sur la partie européenne tel
que nous l'a notifié il n'est pas
perverse mais les mathématiques c'était
de dire si on utilise les 5 milliards
pour rembourser une partie des 60 liés
au déboursement français à ce moment là
on perd 5 milliards sur l'ensemble du
plan donc est ce que c'est voilà
contrairement ce que je veux dire c'est
arrive c'est fait les 5 milliards ce qui
son aspect affectés sur l'e40 c'est bien
saint patrice à ce qu'on avait soit
respectée sur les 40 du total fasse une
partie c'est une première tranche des 40
et quelques que la france touchera après
il ya deux autres éléments qui sont
importants qui doivent être encore
précisés mais qui sont successifs à ce
préfinancement c'est que le
préfinancement ça n'est qu' une partie
de ce coût ne touchera en 2021 bien sûr
et j'espère qu'en 2021 on touchera plus
de 13% de l' enveloppe totale française
du plan de relance c'est bien l'objectif
puisque on devrait toucher même plus
d'un tiers de ce total donc c'est un
montant important et comme vous le savez
ces deux derniers points parce qu'il
intéresse en particulier les
collectivités les régions au premier
chef
nous sommes en train discuter que j'ai
tenus moore pour dans la partie du plan
de relance national des 100 milliards
d'euros qui est territorialisée parfois
contractualiser avec les régions qui est
indépendant du découpage europe france
mais dans ces 100 milliards d'euros et
auteur ou territorialise au maximum et
ont contractualisé au maximum il faut
qu'on indique aux régions c'est une
exigence de leur part et de l'union
européenne ce qui relève du financement
européen ou pas et ça c'est le travail
que nous sommes en train de finaliser ce
qui permettra de dire aussi dans chaque
type de contrat entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales des régions
en l'occurrence de savoir ce qui est
européen ou pas c'est un peu la
présentation parce que la fin
d'importance économiquement c'est qu'on
avait 40 milliards d'euros d'argent
européen et leur fléchage exact à la
limite et est un peu moins important
mais ça permet aussi aux régions de
savoir ce qui provient de l'europe
en complément des fonds de cohésion à
travers le plan de relance européen
question puisqu'on est sur ce sujet on
sait pas exactement delà de la question
du plan de relance et donc de la
pandémie
ces 40 milliards et justement j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure le le fonds
d'ajustement du break si tu paye donc
les 5 milliards à l'enveloppent
budgétaire européenne dont je ne sais
plus près de 600 millions seront de 300
millions seront seront versés à la
france
eux aussi sont contractualisés dans ce
cadre là c'est un ensemble dans la
contractualisation alors c'est une
contractualisation à part permettant
parce que finalement les dépenses
effectuées en termes d'ajustement brac
site
elles ont été effectuées en général par
les régions alors ça c'est un point que
l'on clarifié dans les modalités du
règlement du fonds d'ajustement grec
cite mais il y aura normalement une
discrétion assez grande mais c'est à
chaque état membre donc là aussi la
commission regarde les choses en deux
temps générales définies par les
critères qu'elle a posés dans ce
règlement
ce qui revient à chaque secteur et à
chaque étape est donc à la fin de forme
d' enveloppe nationale est libre aux
états membres en fonction des secteurs
concernés et des investissements qui ont
été faits par exemple par les
collectivités mais aussi par les ports
de contractualiser si chaque état le
souhaitent en faisant sauter le verrou
juillet 2020 lequel bas parce qu'en fait
les dépenses ne sont prises en compte
qu'à partir de juin
donc moi je pense que ça doit être un
combat de la france et votre combat nous
un autre ni la d'avancer la date
d'éligibilité lorsqu'on a fait déjà pour
le plan de relance d'ailleurs puisque ça
commence au 1er février 2020 les
dépenses éligibles
mais ce qui n'est pas encore le cas où
il avait raison désolé de vous avoir
fait le premier règlement briques si
l'on pourra leur préciser puisque mais
interrogé sur ce point pour être clair
en l'état il n'est pas satisfaisant du
point de vue français parce que les
critères de répartition sectorielle ne
sont pas mauvais parce qu'il donne une
priorité importante au secteur de la
pêche qui était notre priorité affichée
la logique même du fonds d'ajustement de
réussite puisque c'est d'aider les
secteurs et les régions les plus
touchées
mais du point de vue de l'intérêt
français pris dans son ensemble
l'enveloppent temps ont bénéficié à la
france nous apparaît aujourd'hui trop
limité donc nous travaillons sur les
critères évidemment comme c'est un
montant donné c'est un gâteau dont
grossissement d'une tranche correspond
au rétrécissement de la tranche de
l'autre et a donc c'est un combat
compliqué vous êtes vous allez me
trouver ta came ça ça compense en partie
la tristesse du fait amp dans le dans le
plan de relance dans le plan de
financement parce que le fait on va
quand même pas été très servi il a été
rattrapé mais il n'a pas été très servi
vous avez raison il a été rattrapé et
par rapport à l'ambition de le portillon
et n'est pas totalement satisfaisant
c'est certain mais j'insiste sur le fond
brice intel qui est des jeux proposés en
revanche sur la pêche les enveloppes
prévues sont importantes si vous le
pensez vous le voulez bien je passerai
au projet de résolution sur le futur de
la politique
la résolution pardon qui a été adoptée
sur la politique agricole commune et des
mesures à prendre en temps de crise qui
était une résolution de juin 2020 aux
rapports aussi de l'ancien président
visé
pour sauf si vous avez d'autres
précisions sur mais on pourra y revenir
ensuite sur le cadre budgétaire lui même
très bien alors cette résolution avait
fait le constat de la fragilité du
secteur agricole européen français en
particulier en temps de crise et de la
nécessité pour l'union européenne de lui
venir en aide
en adaptant ses règles notamment dans le
domaine de la concurrence et je partage
avec remise de l'agriculture je viens de
normandie votre conviction
nous avons là un chantier qui n'est pas
fini je peux dire quelques mots de
l'état d'avancée des mesures d'urgence
mais un chantier le fond qui n'est pas
finie sur l'adaptation des règles de
concurrence nous avons l'occasion d'en
parler à plusieurs reprises le devant
votre commission à la politique agricole
aux négociations commerciales dans le
secteur agricole
c'est clair que c'est un chantier qui
n'est pas encore assez avancé je crois
que nous partageons là aussi la même
conviction de réformes alors sur les
mesures d'urgence plus spécifiquement la
commission avait proposé sous notre
impulsion dès le mois d'avril une plus
grande flexibilité des instruments de la
pac
face à la crise avec la prolongation du
délai de dépôt des demandes dead ainsi
que des avances de paiement plus élevé
on était passé à 70 % au lieu de 50 pour
les paiements directs à 85 % au lieu de
75 pour les paiements liés au
développement rural au second pilier
l'union a également développé c'était je
crois plus important encore des mesures
d'urgence financière avec le
renforcement du feader au titre du plan
de relance nous l'avons évoqué mais
avant même cela en se dotant d'un paquet
de mesures de marché
cela avait pris quelques semaines au
printemps dernier mais nous l'avions
obtenu avec l'activation des de stockage
privé particulier pour les produits
laitiers pour la viande une dérogation
aux règles de concurrence face à la
crise pour certains secteurs et des
flexibilités pour la gestion de
plusieurs programmes notamment dans le
secteur de la viticulture dont nous
savons pour cette filière viticole qu'
il ya une forme de double crise ou de
double peine si je puis dire
combinant les effets de la crise
économique comme pour beaucoup de
secteurs agricoles et les effets des
mesures commerciales américaines
qui touchait tout particulièrement la
viticulture ce qui avait donné lieu à un
plan de soutien national présenté par le
premier ministre et je viens de
normandie cet été mais aussi à ses
mesures de soutien européenne nous
demandons encore à la commission de
suivre attentivement ces mesures de
marché et d'envisager de nouvelles
mesures si nécessaire ainsi que pour la
viticulture c'est un combat qui n'a pas
encore trouvé son aboutissement je le
dis sincèrement sur des mesures de
soutien financier accru au niveau
européen en complément des efforts
nationaux que nous portons même si là
aussi pour précis sur ces cette double
crise notre premier combat
c'est évidemment de lever les mesures de
tarifs commerciaux imposé par les
américains contre le secteur de la
viticulture en rétorsion rétorsion dont
nous contestons la légalité et le fair
play dans une relation entre alliés en
ce qui concerne plus généralement la
négociation liées à la réforme de la pac
que vous avez évoquées à monsieur le
président notre conviction je l'évoqué
sur le plan budgétaire et que cette
politique reste centrale elle doit
apporter une sécurité alimentaire une
qualité alimentaire défendre le standard
sanitaires et environnementaux auxquels
compris en matière de d'accords
commerciaux
j'y reviendrai en maintenant des coûts
raisonnables et l' équilibre qui était
trouvée au conseil en octobre 2020
reprend une large partie des demandes de
la france et demande que le sénat avait
porté dans le cadre des trilogues qui
sont encore en cours entre le parlement
et le conseil en particulier nous sommes
particulièrement vigilants en matière
d'architecturé environnementales les
règles de la conditionnalité ce qu'on
appelle les échos régime les échos ce
qui m' en mauvais français ou les seuils
minimaux de dépenses environnementales
la simplification du modèle de mise en
oeuvre les souplesse de gestion
financière et l'introduction d'un droit
à l'erreur comme on l'appelait font
également partie des priorités que la
france défend tout comme les aides
couplées en lien avec le développement
des surfaces de protéines végétales et
la préservation des mécanismes dead aux
zones en situation de handicap naturel
je tiens à préciser aussi puisque c'est
à la fois une forme de soutien régional
mais de politique agricole
bien sûr que par notre mobilisation
appuyé par de nombreux parlementaires
nationaux et européens avec je viens de
normandie avec le ministre d outre-mer
sébastien lecornu
nous avons pu maintenir aussi dans la
dernière ligne droite à la fin des
années 2020 dans les négociations avec
le parlement européen le maintien du
budget du programme dit pose est si
important pour l'agriculture de nos
outre-mer et ce programme était remis en
cause
comme vous le savez jusqu'à la fin de
l'année dernière en matière de règles de
concurrence
notre position est la vôtre me
semble-t-il pu vise à rendre possible
extension d'accord interprofessionnel
permettant la constitution de fonds de
mutualisation pour prévenir différents
risques sur la santé animale sur le plan
économique ou sur le plan
environnemental et nous souhaitons
également intégré mieux les coûts de
production dans les dispositions
relatives au partage de la valeur
renforcer ainsi la encadrement des
relations contractuelles pense notamment
aux secteurs du lait en matière ô
combien sensible de commerce
international et d'accords commerciaux
sujets que nous avons aussi évoqué à
plusieurs reprises devant votre
commission et devant votre assemblée
en général nous devons être les plus
vigilants possible offensif qu'à
reconquérir des marchés international
est aussi une condition de vie ou de
survie de notre agriculture nationale ne
vont pas sur une position uniquement
défensive mais sans accepter non plus
des accords commerciaux qui ne
respecteraient pas nos standards de
qualité environnementale alimentaire de
production que ce soit dans le secteur
agricole ou industrielle et je veux
redire ici notamment sur la question de
l'accord le plus connu puisque celui qui
est sur la table de l'union européenne
depuis un peu plus d'un an celui sur le
mercosur la position de la france est
claire elle n'a pas changé l'accord
existant n'est pas acceptable si c'est
un nouvel accord en accord qui ait été
modifié sur les points que vous
connaissez en matière de biodiversité de
respect de l'accord de paris et 2
et de respect là aussi de nos standards
environnementaux sanitaires alimentaires
ce serait une autre discussion mais
l'accord qui existe n'est pas acceptable
pour la france et que cette position est
largement partagé je tenais à l'art
précisé comme je l'évoquais en
introduction la politique agricole
commune je n'insiste pas lourdement sera
renforcé sur le plan budgétaire
avec cette légère augmentation d'1 5% en
valeur par rapport au cadre financier
précédent pour la france cela signifie
un montant d'être direct avant un
éventuel transfert qui serait de 50
milliards 51 milliards d'euros pardon
pour les aides directes contre 52 9 sur
la période précédente
mais un deuxième pilier qui lui seraient
en forte augmentation passant de 9,9 à
11,4 milliards d'euros le jeu des
transferts qui est une pratique
autorisée évidemment est habituel que le
mystérieux tueur est en train de
regarder nous permettra de stabiliser le
montant des aides directes
s'agissant de la résolution concernant
la modernisation de la politique
européenne de concurrence qui a quelques
liens avec le sujet agricole mais qui
est évidemment de porter beaucoup plus
large adopté en juillet 2020 au rapport
des sénateurs châtillon et hainaut je
voulais redire les actions que nous
menions dans ce sens d'abord la france
l'allemagne mais aussi la pologne et
l'italie ont appelé par leur ministre de
l'économie à une modernisation et une
réforme profonde du droit de la
concurrence européen pour l'adapter aux
objectifs d'une politique industrielle
et d'une concurrence internationale qui
nécessite de revoir un stand de nos
concepts profond de politique de
concurrence européenne et le
gouvernement ainsi soutenu dans l'esprit
de votre résolution trois initiatives
essentielles d'autres mais trois
initiatives essentielles qui sont
portées par la commission européenne qui
ont été portées par la commission
européenne au cours de l'année 2020
notamment par le commissaire thierry
breton
la vice présidente margret devait styger
d'abord un projet de révision de la
définition du marché du marché pertinent
qui date de 1997
c'était un des points clés de votre
résolution et de vos expressions
diverses
ce qui n'est plus adapté aux à la
concurrence internationale notamment
chinoise que nous vivons aujourd'hui
deuxième élément très important c'est la
publication en 2020 également d'un livre
blanc j'y reviendrai sur les subventions
étrangères et la régulation des
subventions étrangères c'est un élément
de distorsion de la concurrence très
important sur le marché européen
auxquels nous devons répondre et qui
n'étaient pas dans le panorama de nos
règles de concurrence jusqu'à présent et
puis la proposition de règlement vous
aviez fait à lui vous y aviez fait
allusion monsieur le président relatifs
au marché équitable est contestable dans
le secteur du numérique ce qu'on appelle
de manière parfois plus rapide le dm a
présenté le 15 décembre dernier dans un
paquet numérique d'ensemble par madame v
styger et monsieur breton
un mot sur ce texte qui vise de manière
très importante et c'était une position
la vôtre et celle de la france que nous
défendions qui vise la régulation ex
ante et des grandes plateformes
numériques je crois qu'on envoie
particulier à la lumière de la crise
toute l'importance l'objectif c'est trop
long et de garantir que les marchés
numériques rester innovant est ouvert à
la concurrence et surtout que les
relations commerciales avec ces grandes
plateformes ces grands acteurs
numériques que chacun connaît soit
équitable il prévoit à ce titre un
mécanisme contrôle du respect des règles
de concurrence fondée sur les enquêtes
de marché et des obligations
supplémentaires pour ces grands acteurs
en fonction de seuils qui sont définies
dans ce dans ce texte
nous serons très attentifs puisque nous
sommes au début du processus législatif
européen ce que les négociations qui
s'engagent conforte ses ambitions et
notamment plus précisément que la
commission puisse bénéficier le très
large pouvoir d' enquêtes qu'elle puisse
adopter des mesures conservatoires et ce
qu'on appelle des remèdes
comportementaux ou structurel
concrètement il s'agit de faire en sorte
que la politique de concurrence puisse
agir en amont et imposer des obligations
aux plateformes
plutôt que en aval on voit l'activisme
de la commission bienvenue face à
quelques grands acteurs du numérique
google par exemple avec de nombreuses
enquêtes de concurrence parfois des
amendes très significative mais qui
arrive cinq à sept ans après la
commission des faits et donc ne
réorganisent pas le marché et ne corrige
pas les atteintes à la concurrence je
rappelle pour donner ce seul exemple que
google par exemple ses 97 % en europe du
marché du moteur de recherche
donc on a des situations de quasi
monopole là les règles de concurrence
actuelle intervenants ex post et
longtemps ex post ne permettent pas de
répondre à ces risques de marché hélas
ces risques de concurrence
les orientations de votre résolution
portait au delà de la question de la
régulation numérique sur ces deux points
que j'évoquais et c'est pour ça que je
citais les trois initiatives de la
commission
la révision de la communication relative
aux marchés pertinents
le sénat demandait l'actualisation de la
définition du marché et la prise en
compte de la concurrence potentielle
future
derrière ce terme se cache l'essentiel
de l'enjeu
ce que nous l'avons vu sur le marché du
ferroviaire par exemple si l'on regarde
le marché actuel ou des prévisions
raisonnables sur cinq ou sept ans ou dix
ans la concurrence étrangère est assez
faible mais nous avons vu que parfois
nous l'avons vécu malheureusement sur
des industries comme les panneaux
photovoltaïques
quand quelques années une concurrence
non anticipés d'acteurs chinois ou
autres peuvent balayer un marché
européen mais donc revoir le marché
pertinent pour prendre en compte la
dimension mondiale de la concurrence
actuelle et pas seulement le marché
européen ou national et est absolument
fondamentale nous continuons à emporter
avec vous cette exigence auprès de la
commission européenne
et je dis un mot sur le règlement que je
pointait du doigt le projet de règlement
sur les subventions étrangères distorted
de concurrence là aussi derrière ce
terme barbare se cache un outil
fondamental
un livre blanc a donc été publiés par la
commission l'an dernier pour recueillir
vos impressions
et dès la fin du premier semestre c'est
l'engagement de la commission en perd un
texte législatif un projet de règlement
sera soumis
au parlement européen et au conseil si
l'on suit les propositions du livre
blanc il pourrait très ambitieux et
permettent par exemple de d'empêcher
l'accès au marché ou de d'imposer des
amendes très significatives à des
entreprises non européennes qui
investirait en europe participeraient
des marchés publics européens tout en
étant subventionnés par les autorités
publiques de leur propre pays et ça je
crois que c'est le vrai sujet d'équité
des conditions de concurrence sur le
marché européen
aussi parce que l'on voit bien que on
est évidemment plus compétitif quand on
est très largement subventionnée à la
maison et qu'on peut casser les prix
pour le dire très clairement sur le
marché européen si l'union européenne
aujourd'hui n'a aucun instrument pour
faire face à cette atteinte aux règles
de concurrence puisque nos règles de
concurrence n'ont pas été faites pour
cette compétition mondiale mais pour les
compétitions européennes commencent donc
c'est l'autre combat que nous menons
dans l'esprit aussi de votre résolution
j'ai déjà été long monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis prêt néanmoins bien sûr à compléter
à s'attendre de réponse sur ces trois
résolutions ces trois ensembles de
résolution sur les trois thèmes que nous
avons évoqués ou a précisé d'autres
points et puis ensuite à continuer notre
échange sur les quatre autres thèmes que
vous avez souhaité mettre en exergue
bien jeu alors je ne sais pas chez nos
collègues qui sont connectés il ya
petits dés
des demandes de
de prise de parole non il n'y en a pas
il ya eu des demandes de prise de parole
par décoller conect madame bruni donc je
vais prendre ma madame bruni ensuite je
laisserai pas très joli sur le cfp
notamment probablement à toi pascal oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur
monsieur le ministre
alors moi je voulais revenir au sujet de
la pac sur les réflexions de la
commission européenne en termes de
stratégie biodiversité au sein de ce
qu'on appelle le green deal sont
manifestement fondée sur l'idée de
décroissance
alors comment particulier prévoir à
l'horizon 2030
c'est seulement 9 ans et en agriculture
c'est ça fait beaucoup moins
donc comment peuvent-ils renoncer à 10 %
de la surface agricole utile européenne
tout en diminuant de 50 % l'utilisation
des pesticides
donc à ce sujet la recherche la
substitution d'autres pratiques
agricoles et en quadruplant aussi à 25%
les terres convertis au bio sans de
facto prononcé à l'agriculture
traditionnelle et donc derrière assurer
un revenu décent à ceux qui doivent
nourrir la planète
nos agriculteurs donc compétitivité et
bien sûr alimentation saine et puis dans
nos propositions on a souvent évoqué le
sujet de la renationalisation de la pac
pour lequel nous sommes très inquiet
parce que derrière c'est bien sûr des
distorsions de concurrence
supplémentaire et du dumping social et
environnemental
voilà n'est question merci beaucoup
comme les sujets sont différents
monsieur mini jeux vous propose de
répondre question par question
alors sur le web pendant sur les
objectifs 2030 nous veillons justement
dans la négociation c'est la culture sur
la plus précis que moi mais c'est ce à
quoi a veillé le ministère l'agriculture
est ce que ce à quoi nous veillons dans
les négociations en trilogue aujourd'hui
à ce que nous ne mettions pas des
objectifs intenables ou qui remettent en
cause un modèle agricole notamment
français à l'horizon 2030
je prends un exemple vous avez cité la
question des surfaces agricoles ou de la
conversion bio il ya un exemple qui me
paraît important et qui était un combat
commun je crois dans cette nouvelle pac
c'est la question des échos régime plus
simplement mentionné si nous avons pas d
s'ils ne vont pas des régimes d'aeria de
questions pour être précis à la question
des pourcentages déco régime entre 20 et
30% sont discutées actuellement entre le
conseil et le parlement
mais il ya surtout plus important
la question de leur caractère
obligatoire typiquement si nous n'avions
pas de caractère obligatoire européens
et que la france le faisais et que
d'autres pays ne faisait pas là on
remettrait en cause notre modèle et on
ne casserait la compétitivité non
seulement de l'agriculture européenne
vis-à-vis d'autres acteurs
internationaux mais de la france
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires européens
et donc typiquement là dessus je crois
que il faut mettre non pas pour embêter
les agriculteurs au contraire le plus de
règles obligatoires européenne possible
pour éviter que nous nous irons les
obligations avec nos partenaires
européens ne l'est pas c'est exactement
la proche que l'on essaie de développer
aujourd'hui sur le glyphosate par
exemple pour ne pas avoir une politique
française qui vous tirer une balle dans
le pied par rapport à nos partenaires
européens ce qui ne serait ni efficace
environnementalement n'est soutenable
économiquement sur la renationalisation
de la pac pour être tout à fait honnête
c'est une question qu'on s'est déposée
au tout début de la négociation
je crois pour exactement pour cette même
raison il n'ya pas il doit pas y avoir
de tabou mais je crois que ça ne serait
pas du tout la meilleure façon de
défendre l'agriculture française
pourquoi d'abord parce que c'est une
politique intégrée je veux pas être dans
le symbole mais je le disais tout à
l'heure la première depuis 58 ans je
crois qu'il aura en effet détricotage du
budget européen de beaucoup de
politiques communes si on commençait par
celle ci elle bénéficie évidemment en
premier lieu à la france mais on
pourrait dire que finalement à travers
un budget national augmente et nous
pourrions faire le même effort financier
mais je crois qu'on perdrait surtout le
même levier même si c'est encore très
imparfait d'égalisation d'harmonisation
des normes agricoles ou des soutien
financier à l'agriculture entre pays
européens
si on veut pas se créer une compétition
interne à l'europe qui s'ajouterait à la
compétition externe que je décrivais
accords commerciaux etc
je crois que en nationalisant la pac
on courait massivement ce risque et donc
c'est pour ça que cette option qui peut
avoir parfois d entretenir des fantasmes
sur le plan budgétaire en se disant on
aurait plus d'argent au niveau national
ce terrain je crois que ce n'est pas
exact tellement nous avons un bon taux
de retour sur la pac et le meilleur taux
de retour de toutes les politiques
européens sur la france oui
non monsieur le ministre excusez moi
c'est justement l'inversé que le projet
de la pac nous nous laisse à penser
qu'ils auraient en fait une
renationalisation avec du coup des
distorsions de concurrence c'est pas moi
mon souhait c'est justement ce soit par
ou nationalisés que ça reste bien
entendu une compétence uniquement
européenne pardon je vois bien que vous
ne détruirez pas la renationalisation
mais je revenais là dessus un peu trop
longue en mai sur le sur le nouveau
modèle de pâques et les risques du coup
qu'on aille vers une forme de
renonciation de fait avec plus de
liberté donnée à chaque état membre
je le disais au début je crois que on a
le plus possible éviter ce risque
maintenant dans l'exécution en avant la
finalisation de la réforme négociée en
trilogue et ensuite dans l'exécution par
la commission européenne
il faut s'assurer que la marge de
manoeuvre qui revenait à chaque pays ne
soit pas au détriment de règles communes
d'où l'importance d'en définir le plus
possible sans être excessivement
bureaucratique mais le plus possible je
pensais aux échos régime par exemple
mais aussi que dans l'exécution
la commission européenne vérifie que les
programmes nationaux qui me seront
soumis soit le plus cohérent possible je
pense que cette marge de manoeuvre à les
bienvenus pour éviter un ce terme de
lourdeur de paiement des dispositifs de
la pac qu'on a beaucoup discuté et c'est
pour ça que je disais qu'ils aient
toujours parfois revient ce fantasme la
relation de la renault signe de la
renationalisation pas par votre
expression mais plus généralement et on
s'était je le disais sincèrement posé la
question tout début de la négociation vu
la proposition budgétaire de la
commission mais on l'a réhaussé je pense
maintenant il faut faire attention à ce
que la commission européenne ne
démantèle pas de defacto le caractère
intégré la pac dans les programmes qui
seront soumis après d'options de la
réforme et je ne crois pas que ce soit
l'intention de la dg agri et du
commissaire avec lequel je viens de
normandie et moi nous sommes entretenu à
ce sujet à plusieurs reprises
donc si monsieur présidence lui ce merci
pour clarté de vos propos 3 3 questions
pour rebondir sur ce qui peut être dit
sur les accords commerciaux et les
enjeux notamment dans le domaine
agricole n'est pas seulement c'est
qu'avec le lac aux sourds elle c'était à
font l'objet d'une application
on anticipe au provisoire pour une
partie d'un talent pour ce qui relève de
l'union européenne j'aimerais savoir
exactement ce qu'il en est très
précisément ça n'est pas très clair dans
ce que l'on ce que l'on en sait deuxième
point concernant le budget communautaire
il est la négociation qui s'est achevée
en fin d'année on sait que la france au
cours de ces dernières années n'a pas
été nécessairement toujours dans des
consommation optimale des crédits
budgétaires quelles sont les
dispositions que le gouvernement
envisage de prendre pour que dans la
future une période cette consommation
soit améliorée et qu'elles sont d'alors
les aujourd'hui les discussions
négociations qui lie avec les
gestionnaires territoriaux de ces fonds
troisième sujet concerne les ressources
propres et je voudrais m'attacher à
évoquer le mécanisme d'ajustement
carbone aux frontières
la commission européenne doit
normalement faire des propositions d'ici
la fin de ce semestre
le
ça a été évoqué récemment à la au
parlement européen dans le cadre de la
commission idoine
le rapporteur est le président de cette
commission ont souhaité qu'il y ait une
forte qu'ils ont entre ce mécanisme est
celui du système des changes des quotas
d'émissions notamment concernant les
modalités de fixation des prix du
carbone de le président de la commission
pascal canfin cette occasion évoqué le
risque qu'il pourrait y avoir en liant
les deux d'abord peut-être contraint par
la règle de l'unanimité qui rend plus
difficile l'aboutissement de la
négociation mais surtout que 7e ces
modalités d'organisation d'articulation
pourrait être rejeté par l'om c'est
comme constituant une mesure
protectionniste que j'aimerais avoir
votre avis sur l'analyse de cette
situation et puis par ailleurs la france
va avoir en charge à partir du premier
semestre de l'année prochaine
ces questions là comment la france
envisage de travailler sur ces sujets je
remercie
sur les trois points mais ceux ci attend
le succès est un joli un point sur
lequel serait rapide parce que elle
relève davantage de de mon collègue de
l'agriculture mais qui est important
évidemment c'est l'accélération des des
dispositifs nationaux de versement des
aides qui ont été beaucoup complexifiés
ce nra zones et c'est un des points
positifs je crois du modèle nouveau que
propose la commission aussi on s'en
saisit de manière efficace mais c'est
encore devant nous de le définir dans
l'année qui vient
puisque nous avons vous le savez un
délai avant la mise en oeuvre de la
nouvelle pac
d'abord pour finir les négociations et
ensuite pour sa mise en oeuvre
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2022 et donc
nous devrons effectivement définir les
sportifs d'accélération nous avons plus
de marge de manoeuvre par rapport à de
mons financier européen dans la
définition des circuits de financement
que la france mettra en place d'un
nouvel période donc c'est encore devant
nous mais je pense c'est un des
avantages de cette non pas de cette
renationalisation
mais de cette marge de manoeuvre
supplémentaire qui nous aider c'est
parce que vous le savez mieux que moi
dans un certain nombre de cas c'est vrai
aussi pour les fonds de cohésion
les retards de versements nous l'avons
vécu encore en 2017 en arrivant sur
beaucoup d'éléments des paiements
directs
nous sommes en retard parce que nous
avons complexifier nous mêmes les
circuits de versement et de financement
donc il est encore un peu un peu tôt
pour dire exactement comment nous le
ferons mais cela c'est l'enjeu de cette
souplesse supplémentaire donnée aux
états membres dans la nouvelle politique
agricole sur les accords commerciaux
pour être très clair
bon d'abord il y en a je crois trois qui
sont dans le paysage je ne mets pas
volontairement le sais tape un statut
différent étant dans l'application
provisoire
celui du mercosur j'ai rappelé la
position très claire notamment pour des
raisons agricole mais plus largement
parce que les engagements en termes de
biodiversité de standards alimentaires
sanitaires environnementaux et du
respect général de la cour de paris ne
sont pas assurés et puis à deux autres
accords qui sont dans les tuyaux si je
peux le formuler ainsi qu'ils sont celui
le projet d'accord avec l'australie le
projet d'accord avec la nouvelle zélande
qui portait aussi des enjeux agricoles
importants la fois être clair je pense
qu'il n'y a aucune
même si une pression en ce sens de
certains états membres jeu
dis très franchement il n'y a aucune
urgence à précipiter et conclure des
accords qui portent principalement en
termes d'enjeux pour la france sur la
question avec talent et la concurrence
potentielle porte avant tout sur
certains secteurs agricoles filière
laitière filières d'élevage que nous ne
sacrifierons pas à l'aune d'une sorte de
religion de l'accord commercial
quand je vais être très clair j'insiste
sur un point vous avez déjà entendu le
dire mais je crois que c'est très
important politiquement et je peux me
permettre
j'inviterais aussi votre assemblée votre
commission à l'utiliser comme levier
vous attendent éventuelle résolution
ultérieure c'est l'accord sur le break
site paradoxalement parce que l'accord
sur le prêt que cite le savon amplement
discuté avec le prix l'an rapin dans
beaucoup de d'aspects notamment
halieutiques a pour la première fois
parce que c'est aussi un accord
commercial c'est avant tout un accord
conventionnel un certain nombre de
règles qu'on a appelée de level playing
field concurrence équitable vous
souvenez de nos échanges sur ce point
mais qui en matière agricole en matière
environnementale en matière industrielle
en matière d'être d'état etc comportent
des mécanismes de vérification du
respect par l'autre partie en espèces le
royaume uni de nos standards qui sont
uniques et qui je crois on a deux enjeux
comme vous le savez un calibre exceed
c'est de faire en sorte que maintenant
ces nouveaux standards soient bien
respectées bien appliquées et c'est
encore un chantier qui est devant nous
avec des mesures autonomes qu'on va
adopter dans les prochains mois ça c'est
une chose due au laxisme et sur notre
sujet ça veut dire aussi que cette boîte
à outils supplémentaires qu'on a créé
dans la course une brique site
elle est donc possible elle existe et
donc mutatis mutandis on doit pouvoir
l'appliquer à d'autres accords
commerciaux
donc moi je compte bien avec franck
riester avec je viens de normandie dans
la négociation des accords commerciaux
l'utiliser pour dire vous voyez bien que
ce qu'on a fait
la barque on a placé beaucoup plus haut
que d'habitude en termes de respect des
standards
certes pour un partenaire qui est
infiniment plus importants sur le plan
des flux commerciaux que le canada que
l'australie la nouvelle zélande
on doit pouvoir les utiliser dans ces
nouveaux et d'accords commerciaux et je
dirais même qu'on leur en faire la
condition d'accepter
méditez de nouveaux accords commerciaux
et vous avons été très clairs sur le
fait que par exemple le respect de
l'accord de paris comme clause
essentielle de tout accord commercial
qui figure dans l'accord sur le mexique
doit être repris dans les accords
commerciaux éventuel conclurait donc pas
qu'on leur fermer la porte par principe
à tout accord commercial qui est pas
forcément diabolique en soi mais en
revanche réformer profondément le modèle
commercial européen qui va encore qui
est encore trop imprégné de la logique
d'origine qui est l ouverture à tout
prix la baisse des droits de douane la
plus rapide possible
ça c'est un logiciel qui doit être
terminée et on doit su utiliser nos
discussions actuelles comme franck
riester sur la question du mercato et
surtout l'accord sur le break site pour
relever le niveau d'ambition dans tout
possible accord commercial
voilà pour être clair le panorama actuel
sur la question des ressources propres
elle est très importante
la ressource qu'on appelle parfois
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières
taxe carbone aux frontières européennes
mais ce n'est pas une taxe littéralement
elle est la plus cool sans doute la plus
importante parce que là aussi ça
changerait la colère commercial
c'est-à-dire qu'on on obligerait tout
exportateur vers l'union européenne sur
un sujet aussi central que les exigences
climatiques environnementales à
respecter nos standards et à payer pour
se mettre à notre niveau d'ambition donc
c'est un changement majeur
ci-après pourrait se décliner dans
d'autres domaines
c'est la plus importante je crois des
ressources propres a créé et c'est
probablement sur le plan juridique et
technique la plus compliquée il est
possible d'avoir un système nous avons
travaillé avec le ministère de
l'écologie en particulier d'avoir un
système le décrivait je crois
précédemment ici miroir du système que
vous évoquez le système d'échangé de
quotas ou du système 10 pts c'est à dire
qu'en gros on ferait acheter des quotas
carbone l'équivalent de quotas carbone
sera exactement la même chose aux
exportateurs pour qu'ils aient le même
niveau d'exigence et de même prix du
carbone à payer que nos propres
producteurs et ce système là je suis pas
l'expert technique mais
nous sommes convaincus qu'il ya une voie
de passage juridique pour le rendre
compatible avec les règles de l'om c'est
en raison de sa finalité
environnementale ça n'empêche pas qu'il
rapporte des ressources mais il doit
avoir une finalité environnementale
justifié pour être accepté dans le cadre
des règles de l'om sait nous pensons que
c'est possible et c'est d'ailleurs après
avoir longtemps été réticente sur ce
point le diagnostic aussi de la
commission européenne aujourd'hui elle
fera dans le semestre
une proposition juridique cet égard je
pense que pour à s'assurer de son
caractère robuste sur le plan
opérationnel juridiques etc et ne pas
tuer cette belle idée surtout pas il
faudrait à mon sens commencé par
quelques secteurs
c'est comme ça à mon avis que nous
réglerons les doutes juridiques et
politiques qui se posent encore
nous n'avons évoqué ensemble je crois à
plusieurs reprises c'est notamment le
secteur du ciment notamment le secteur
de l'acier certains pensent aux
fertilisants par exemple l'aluminium qui
sont autant de produits sur lesquels il
y à des processus de production
suffisamment organisés au niveau mondial
pour qu'on puisse comparer et mettre un
prix du carbone évaluables à des
exportateurs non européens qui veulent
vendre en europe
voilà pour ces sujets pour faire le lien
pardon c'était notre dernier point avec
la présence française de l'union
européenne bien sûr nous espérons que
cela avance avant ce qui aura la
proposition je l'évoquais d'ici la fin
du semestre
une discussion initiative qui commencera
au second semestre 2021 mais nous
espérons bien que la présence française
soit un accélérateur et si possible un
moment d'aboutissement de ces deux
ressources puisque j'évoquais celle sur
le carbone et celle sur le numérique
dans le premier semestre 2022
quand une fois l'ambition commune un
j'assiste du parlement et du conseil et
l'engagement politique commun c'est
d'aboutir avant fin 2022 de toute façon
d'accord ludovic et merci monsieur le
président messieurs ministre chers
collègues dans la lignée directe de ce
que vous venez dire monsieur le ministre
effectivement donc en décembre dernier
vous avez conclu un accord avec le
royaume-uni à l'union européenne a
conclu un accord ' réunis pour un petit
peu guidé les relations futures poste-
briques site vous venez d'en évoquer un
certain nombre d'aspects et je vous en
remercie de manière très précise même si
encore une fois un certain nombre de
sujets sont devant nous mais nous serons
là pour vous y aider modestement le
parlement aux jeunes de toutes les mères
général sera là pour vous y aider
juste au niveau de la sécurité les
limites nous semble encore un petit peu
flou pour le moment et notamment en
termes de cybersécurité et on sait
pertinemment que le royaume uni est un
allié important dans ce domaine là ne
serait ce qu en capacité d écoute et de
et de renseignement je voulais voir avec
vous parce que c'est un sujet qui est
transfrontière c'est bien celui de la
cybersécurité quel est d'après vous un
peu les grands lignes qu'on peut essayer
de d'esquisser aux côtés du royaume uni
et comment d'une manière générale au
niveau européen on peut réussir à
répondre au voeu pieux qui est mieux
pour le moment mais qui ne sera
peut-être pas de travailler ensemble
avec eux tous les pays européens
je remercie
merci merci ludovic mais on est c'était
peut-être déjà la deuxième partie à ce
moment là on garde répondent plus tard
et aucun problème la réponse pour la
deuxième marche très bien mais regardons
y at il d'autres interventions se disait
monsieur le ministre parce que je
voudrais rebondir c'est ce que vous avez
évoquées par rapport donc au domaine
viticole au secteur viticole
parce qu'il y avait eu ces derniers mois
effectivement beaucoup de difficultés
par rapport donc à l'activation de
certaines mécanismes comme ceux de la
distillation de crise il a fallu et
actes au gouvernement d'avoir soutenu
ces demandes là mais alors que c'est
quelque chose qui normalement est
inscrit dans le fonctionnement
européenne c'est chaque fois difficile
d' activer des mécanismes qui sont
prévues c'est simplement la remarque que
je souhaitais faire et même remarque
pour donc le posei puisque chaque fois
s'en reviennent donc comme une musique
lancinante et il faut chaque fois que
nous nous battions que nous intervenons
à nos résolutions des paramètres qui
sont de l'ordre de l'autre qui devrait
être de l'ordre loto de l'automaticité
oui très rapidement monsieur le ministre
moi j'ai noté avec satisfaction que
madame vestiaires admet nécessité de
moderniser son action notamment dans le
cadre de la politique de la colle de la
concurrence et
par rapport à ça il ya une des questions
qui me perturbe quand même c'est la
question des avantages qui sont conférés
par la détention de données par exemple
et
je pense que cette question était
essentielle et que malheureusement elle
n'est que très très rarement prise en
compte
je pense que là aussi il va falloir
intervenir pour mieux répondre aux
nouvelles pratiques de l'économie
digitale sur la détention des données ça
c'est vous avez vous avez complètement
et non c'est un des points sur lesquels
c'est un des points sur lesquels
l'ensemble des adm a d'ailleurs un
troisième texte entend par le moins qui
s'appelle des ga je crois des tutelles
government act doit agir avec plusieurs
aspects en même temps un aspect
indirectes c'est qui est extrêmement
compliqué c'est la question du transfert
des données puisque c'est aussi si je
puis dire la cause source du pouvoir de
marché en matière de détention de donner
des grandes plateformes le fait que
beaucoup de données européenne et je
rappelle que souvent l'union européenne
est le premier marché
les fameuses gaffard ou d'autres géants
du numérique qui capte aussi fun si je
puis dire beaucoup de données y compris
parce que même souvent sans le savoir
c'est locales notamment le beaucoup de
pme françaises elles transfert des
données aux états unis où nous n'avons
pas suffisamment c'est la cour de
justice de l'union européenne qui l'a
dit à deux reprises le garanties sur
l'utilisation qui en est faite publics
ou privés et donc je crois que là nous
aurons à trouver de nouvelles règles ont
discuté la semaine dernière et quatrième
de la cnil pas évidente pour trouver un
cadre de transferts de données parce
qu'on a quand même besoin d'une forme de
circulation mais le plus protecteur
possible pour ne pas renforcer encore le
pouvoir de marché de ces grandes
plateformes avec cette espèce
d'aspiration systématique des données
aux de l'europe vers les états unis pour
être clair est d'ailleurs celle du break
site de l'europe vers le royaume-uni
potentiellement si le royaume uni se
mettait à faire une forme de dumping
réglementaire en matière de données que
nous transférions sans respecter des
règles exigeantes mais la cour de
justice
il veille il veille sur ce point et là
aussi pardon la seule réponse durable
même si le puits ne sera que progressive
c'est de relocaliser
données en europe nous avons des
opérateurs d'ailleurs très efficace au
vih par exemple en france dans les hauts
de france en particulier qui qui qui a
tout à fait la capacité il peut la
développer de stocker des données
européennes massivement et donc je te
dis d'ailleurs pour les entreprises
françaises
la seule solution pour être à la fois
que juridiquement respectueux des règles
européennes et industriellement
protecteur pour ne pas renforcer son
pouvoir de marché c'est le stockage en
europe des données et le font d'ailleurs
de plus en plus elles seront
juridiquement obligé de le faire
progressivement et puis après dans les
règles de concurrence elle même il faut
prendre en compte ce pouvoir de marché
que donne l'accès aux données c'est ce
que fait progressivement
la commission spéciale de chaque cas
détaillé mais dans les cas comme google
parce que au fond l'utilisation enfin le
reproche qui est fait si je dis en
termes de béotiens c'est d'utiliser des
données connues sur les consommateurs
pour priver ses propres produits et donc
c'est exactement l'objet de ce trois
ensemble de textes de prendre en compte
dans les critères de pouvoir de marché
des plateformes la détention massive de
données qu'elles détiennent donc je
crois qu'avec ce sera l'objet de danse
la forme d'amendements législatifs que
la france pourra porter via le
gouvernement mais que le parlement
européen portera aussi dans les mois qui
viennent sur le dessin et des mains pour
que on a fait attention aux la détention
des données comme élément à prendre en
compte pour l'application des nouvelles
règles de concurrence
on essaye d'accélérer un petit peu parce
qu'on a encore une grosse deuxième
partie j'aimerais conclure sur la
première et j'ai encore deux
interventions de rigolade gattolin et
catherine morin desailly pétrier très
rapidement monsieur le ministre toujours
sur la politique de concurrence on a
souvent accusé la commission d'un trop
grand rigorisme sur les aides d'état
depuis la crise du coronavirus il ya eu
de très grande souplesse qui ont été
accordés certain retour laisse penser
que l'allemagne intervient massivement
en terme par rapport à ces industries
par rapport à des rachats et que par
ailleurs structurellement et
sans je dirais
défiance vis-à-vis de ce pays ami
structurellement par l'utilisation du
pouvoir des länder et notamment des
banques des länder l'allemagne un taux
dette publique à son industrie qui est
supérieur à la france encaisse qu'on
dispose aujourd'hui d'un monitoring
sérieux de tout cela parce que
voilà l'allemagne disposant de davantage
de liquidités d'un point de vue
économique on va sans doute sur 2021
continué à lâcher la sur les
aides d'état il faudrait pas qu'on se
retrouve dans une distorsion du coup de
concurrence au sein de la politique de
concurrence notamment avec l'allemagne
plaisir monsieur ministre parce que
madame morin desailly je pense que ce
sera sur le numérique si je me trompe
donc très bien alors je suis rapide
puisque vous me avait aussi invité à
directement dans la réponse
il ya deux choses a dit ce dernier est
la réponse et nous n'avons pas encore
tous les éléments mais la première c'est
ce qui a été déclaré dans le cadre de la
réponse à la crise tant mieux d'ailleurs
la commission européenne à leur appel de
13 mars lever les règles de
d'encadrement des aides d'état habituel
ce qu'on appelle une exit close où les
scripts close en bon français bord mais
une clause de suspension
c'était très important ça bénéficie à
tout le monde donc plus aux grandes
économiques au petit en valeur absolue
d'évidence et à c'est à ce moment là
qu'il se débat important c'est que
l'allemagne a déclaré dans ces régimes
dead qui devrait qui devait néanmoins
être notifié a déclaré un montant total
qui représentait sur l'ensemble union
européenne 50 % des aides des régimes
l'aide notifié la com 51% jeudi de
mémoire dont la moitié pour faire simple
des aides d'état qui était face à la
crise notifié la commission européenne
si l'allemagne représente en gros 25
d'un peu plus de 25 % du pib de l'union
européenne s'étaient donc une sur
représentation très importante
néanmoins ce qu'on voit c'est d'ailleurs
le débat souvent biaisées sur les
comparaisons des efforts budgétaires de
relance ou de d'urgence des différentes
économies européennes c'est que
l'allemagne ait notifié un montant très
important mais des premiers éléments
dont nous disposons montrent qu'elles
n'utilisent pas des enveloppes aussi
importante parce qu a notifié par
exemple des mécanismes de garantie
quand on compare la aussi bruno le maire
le rappelait il ya quelques semaines les
l'ensemble des plans d'urgence et de
relance la france apparaît loin derrière
l'allemagne alors qu aurait été rendre
dépenses selon les cas nous sommes
proportionnellement à égalité voir
devant l'allemagne en termes de soutien
à notre économie
parce que le notifier est plus important
que l'exécuter et donc sur l'exécuter
pour est très simple nous n'avons pas
encore les chiffres mais il est très
probable fin sur les aides d'état
spécifiquement j'entends il est très
probable que l'image se resserrera un
petit peu et que la disproportion
constatés aux bénéfices si je puis dire
de l'allemagne ne sera pas aussi grande
mais c'est un point de vigilance
important sur lequel nous sommes
attentifs et dès qu'on aura les éléments
de comparaison exécuté je voulais
communiquerez bien entendu catherine
conte visible mais ton micro mais ton
micro catherine merci président mais ce
mini jour et rebondir sur la question de
claude kern qui portait sur la
localisation des des données vous avez
évoqué les textes importants en cours le
dma le ds à et l'acte de gouvernance des
données nous travaillons bien sûr nous
sommes au début du processus tri
sélectif ou l'avait rappelé le travail
en salle de commission à l'analyse de
deux de ses textes
vous avez évoqué l'importance de la
localisation des données en europe
je voudrais ajouter localisation et
traitement des données
car c'est un c'est d'un tout et et on
sait bien qu'à partir du moment où des
données sont gérées par des entreprises
qui dépendent d'une hésitation extra
européennes américaines pour ne pas là
la cité c'est là que les problèmes
commencent vous avez cité ovh ovh qui a
fait l'objet d'un débat dans l'hémicycle
au sénat lorsque nous avons évoqué le
traitement des données de santé de la
plateforme air intérieur créé l'année
dernière
pourquoi le choix de microsoft monsieur
le ministre vous avez eu raison de
travaux quai ovh en
ma question est la suivante est ce que
vous allez promouvoir en tant que
ministre des affaires européennes cette
préférence communautaire qui fait partie
finalement de la condition d'une
politique industrielle réussie qui nous
permettra enfin d'en créer un écosystème
du numérique en europe car c'est bien
cela dont on a besoin aussi pour asseoir
notre souveraineté
c'est après c'est assumer cette
préférence communautaire et faire en
sorte que nous soyons déjà à montrer
l'exemple et que le choix des ministères
quand il s'agit de traiter les données
des français soit déjà celui d'une
souveraineté assuré et ce n'est pas du
tout le cas aujourd'hui et je voulais
vous poser la question avez-vous des des
échanges avec vos collègues ministres
sur ces sujets parce que ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui c'est malgré tout
une forme de complaisance avec toutes
ces entreprises extra européennes
américaines pour ne pas les citer et que
a contrario nos entreprises françaises
de dimension européenne interracial se
plaignent de ne jamais être retenu dans
les appels d'offres quand il y à des
appels d'offres oui mr le sila trees
vous avez raison c'est localisation et
traitement des données qui est en kaki
qui est en jeu pour être précis je
prends un exemple puisque vous évoquez
ovh est un opérateur américain que je ne
citerai pas le prends un exemple très
concret pour la présidence française de
l'union européenne
la solution de d'hébergement des données
qui nous était proposé était une
solution non européennes par le conseil
le secrétariat général du conseil de
l'union européenne nous l'avons refusé
et nous mettrons en place peuvent déjà
vous l'annoncer pour prendre un exemple
très concret je suis battu pour cela
avec le secrétariat général de la
présidence française l'union européenne
une solution européenne même française
celle là même que nous avons cités pour
le stockage et le traitement des données
liées à la présidence française de
l'union européenne qui est en forme de
c'est dans les termes de nos techniciens
de ce serveur partager avec des
européens pour que les événements
les documents liés à la présidence
française soit partagée mais nous aurons
une solution française et européenne
pendant cette présidence est l'action de
sensibilisation des collègues parce que
vous avez raison des ministères ont
encore des solutions c'est notre
dépendance hérité ont encore des
solutions non européennes américaines
parfois même plus lointaine de
traitement stockage recours les
logiciels qui ne sont pas européens ou
français
et c'est en train d'être progressivement
corriger c'est notamment ce à quoi va y
aussi le secrétaire d'état cdh et rico
mais nous avons un peu une révolution
culturelle à faire il faut bien le dire
y compris dans la société
quand nous voyons que d'une réticence
sur des applications bien connu pour par
crainte que les autorités publiques
puissent être intrusive il faut être
très vigilant là dessus mais au même
moment toute la journée nous donnons à
des grande gaffe à des informations sur
nous mêmes sans être même conscient au
vigilant sur ce point tant que bons mais
voilà je vous donne un exemple très
concret sur la présidence française qui
dépend directement de moi pour que nous
privilégions parce qu'elle existe des
solutions françaises et européennes
merci merci monsieur ministre alors vous
pour conclure cette première partie moi
mais je reviens sur le sud trois points
essentiels
le premier c'est celui du mercosur en
particulier je sens et ont regardé des
différentes cosaques et des relations
que
j'entame avec mes partenaires européens
présidents de commissions dans les
différents parlements que la position
française me semble un peu isolé donc je
ne sais pas si c'est un ressenti
mais ce n'est pas un sujet qu'on a
évoqué directement mais à chaque fois
qu'il est évoqué on sent une position
française alors elle n'est pas défini
comme tel mais on sent la position des
autres très très allants par rapport à
ces à ces accords ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point vous avez évoqué en
propos introductif introductif et par
rapport au cfp l'europe de la santé les
fameux 5 milliards qui ont été versés
pour une première fois au titre au titre
du budget de la santé
moi je vous donne aussi mon sentiment et
je pense que c'est un travail qui sera
amené de fond parce qu'on parle
énormément d'europe de la santé sans
savoir ce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui l'europe de la santé se
concrétise par le passage de marché
vaccinaux de tests peut-être demain et
puis d'une vision un peu plus généralisé
de ce que peut être les matériels et une
autonomie de conception des matériels de
protection
on a eu un échange au récent au type de
la cosac avec le madame kajaki des cela
est la commissaire chargée de la santé
et franchement franchement j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'en est rien
ressorti c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas on
n'a pas le sentiment d'une vraie volonté
d'europe de la santé des questions
précises lui ont été posées elles
restent sans réponse j'ai d'ailleurs
demandé monsieur le ministre est
peut-être que vous serez un soutien pour
la commission des affaires européennes
du sénat
nous demandons depuis un certain temps
de pouvoir auditionner madame tia qui
dresse ici en commission pour avoir
finalement ne pas pour définir des
règles mais pour essayer de comprendre
quel est cet enjeu de l'europe de la
santé demain ici on essaye de le
décrypter en commission on a des
rapporteurs qui travaille très bien sur
le sujet mais en tout cas on n'a pas de
visibilité
et puis le dernier point c'est l'accord
proche parent etc site je pense et j'ai
entendu de votre
votre bouche que le break si tu pouvais
être un modèle demain deux d'accord
d'accords commerciaux
il faudra effectivement creuser cette
question michel barnier est aujourd'hui
aux côtés de madame von der leyen comme
expert est surveillant de ce que peut
être cet accord pose brac cité je
rappelle à nos collègues nous avons une
audition michel barnier mardi prochain
17h 30 en salle médicis et on pourra
révoquer le juge voilà monsieur le
ministre je ne vous demande pas
forcément de réponses simplement
peut-être sur le mercosur où mon
sentiment est celui ci je ne dis pas que
c'est la vérité mais en tout cas c'est
ce que je ressens
peut-être j'essaie d'être rapides sûres
comme les deux premiers points parce
qu'ils sont sensibles sur le mercosur
vous avez raison que sur le fait que
beaucoup de pays européens ont le
souhait d'avancer et c'est le cas en
particulier du pays qui a la présidence
tournante du conseil de l'union
européenne le portugal mais nous avons
été très clairs franck riester en
particulier l'a rappelé récemment à ses
homologues sur nos exigences et elle ne
diminueront pas une position n'évoluera
pas gelé rappelé tout à l'heure si le
texte évolue aussi le les exigences sont
satisfaites c'est une autre histoire
mais le texte qui est présentée n'est
pas acceptable et je dis moi je veux
voir aussi le verre à moitié plein si je
puis le dire ainsi
c'est que pour la première fois parce
que d'habitude les accords commerciaux
passe de manière quasi automatique au
niveau européen et chez beaucoup de nos
partenaires
pour la première fois jeudi de mémoire
donc j oublie peut-être un ou deux
parlements national parlements nationaux
plusieurs ont d'ores et déjà émis
selon leurs règles respectives des
motions des résolutions pour dire leurs
inquiétudes leurs doutes voire leur
opposition
cela a été le cas en août hambourg en
irlande aux pays-bas et en autriche me
semble-t-il
je le dis de mémoire ce qui est assez
inédit y compris pour des pays qui sont
traditionnellement
sur les catégories un peu simpliste et
très pro commerce et pro ouverture moi
donc je crois qu'il ya comme un
changement d'agenda commercial pour le
prendre plus globalement parce que je
crois que le mercosur ce n'est pas un
sujet isolé l'agenda commercial européen
il est très emblématique bien sûr c'est
pour ça qu'on a vu cette position de
fermeté très clair maintenu le primat
république s'est exprimé extrêmement
fermement en août 2019
c'est notre ligne de conduite c'est le
sujet global de la politique commerciale
européenne que j'évoquais donc je crois
que là-dessus
les choses ont déjà beaucoup bougé c'est
pas gagné encore mais l'accord de paris
comme clause essentielle c'est
maintenant une proposition de la
commission européenne
on l'a intégré pour la première fois
dans l'accord spécifique certes mais sur
le break site
donc je crois que le le paramètre si je
puis dire le logiciel est en train le
paradigme pardon et le logiciel est en
train de changer
pour le dire de manière un peu rapide de
manière plus française que ce n'était le
cas il y a quelques mois encore voilà
donc j'insiste sur ce point je la
position est ferme et notre capacité
d'entraînement je croyais plus
importante qu'il y a quelques mois sur
juste un mot sur la santé puisque je
suis pas tellement d'accord et vous faut
pas que ce soit il faut pas que ce soit
un slogan fort de la santé c'est parfois
comme l'europe sociale lors de la
défense on met le logo et puis après on
sait pas exactement ce qu'on met dans
leurs formes et des actions concrètes
pour moi y en a trois les vaccins je
reviens pas sur tout le débat mais le
cadre l'acquisition de la kz1 plus
largement ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure une sorte de réserve sanitaire
européenne de protection civile en
matière de santé l'acquisition de
masques de gants de respirateurs deux
types de tests européens ça a commencé
sous l'effet de la première vague
nous avons commencé cela et la france
d'ailleurs en a bénéficié elle même à
des moments où nous avions besoin le
soutien avec des gants par exemple est
le troisième élément pour être très
concret on voit bien que c'est notre
manque au fond aujourd'hui en europe
confère le débat vaccinale c'est une
capacité d'investissement dans la
recherche et le développement
non non mais on y repense à ce média
d'abord les vaccins j'aimerais
j'aimerais les vaccins on les a commencé
à les prendre sur les fonds d'urgence
d'ailleurs donc qui les 2,9 milliards
d'euros européens qui ont été investis
ne sont pas prélevés sur les 5 milliards
à ce stade pour avoir un complément mais
et la question de la réserve sanitaire à
un budget spécifique aussi d'ailleurs
qui resquillent où je peux être complété
par le budget de santé et puis l' agence
européenne n'existe pas encore qui
s'inspirerait de labarde américaine
s'est pas simplement pour faire chic
pour faire comme les américains
ces postes bien sûr bien sûr mais je
sais comme le fonds européen de défense
je vous dirai pas ici on y reviendra que
les montants sont suffisants bon mais
c'est une étape et c'est des politiques
sur lesquels il y avait zéro argent
européen es0 actions européennes est
encore quelques mois est ce que je
trouve que ça va assez vite à titre
personnel non est-ce que ça bouge oui et
je crois que la prime la commission
européenne par exemple est parfaitement
consciente de cet enjeu concret sur l'
agence européenne de financement de la
recherche médicale et de la préparation
aux pandémies puisqu'elle va fait la
proposition elle même au moins de
novembre après folâtrant le trouver des
financements complémentaires parce que
quand nous avons défini ce budget y
compris les 5 milliards d'euros nous
n'avions pas encore ses actions
européennes supplémentaires dans le
radar
donc il faut leur en trouver les
financements qui montre au sens le temps
puissance par étape mais je suis sûr que
lors de la santé ça doit être au moins
ces trois choses là pour être concret
notamment avec le fonds européen de la
défense et là je vais demander donc à
dominique de legge et gisèle jourda peut
être de poser leurs questions ont fait
honneur aux dames ont fait honneur si
chers collègues
alors monsieur le ministre vous ne
pouvez pas savoir quelle satisfaction
j'ai de vous
questionné sur le fond européenne de la
défense et vous dire simplement monsieur
le ministre que ceux qui aujourd'hui
semble aller de soi est un acquis une
proposition portée par la commission des
affaires européennes
dès 2016 par une résolution initiée par
yves pozzo di borgo et pas moi même et à
ce moment là nous avons eu presque le
combat des orias et des curiaces on nous
disait que le débat n'était pas de
saison alors que madame homo guérini
nous avait demandé de travailler sur ces
questions là pour donner des
orientations disant que la défense ce
n'était pas tant la défense que l'europe
se fera entendre ce n'était pas le sujet
dont lorsque nous avons vu arriver la
création du fonds européen de la
distance ça a été quelque part pour
notre commission qui avait eu destrem
difficultés je tiens à avoir une pensée
pour monsieur jean bizet et pour donc
simon sutour qui avait soutenu la
démarche ça n'a pas été si simple
je le dis this tout simplement pour dire
que souvent on a l'impression que les
choses vont de soi mais elles sont à
l'origine d'un certain combat et les
plus grands spécialistes sur les
questions de défense à l'époque était
absolument contre est contraire à cette
idée qui donc aujourd'hui n'est plus une
idée mais y met mais qu'une réalité ce
n'est plus un slogan comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le ministre
alors ce fonds européens de la défense
c'est certes un pas important puisqu'il
induit une part d'actions communautaires
dans le domaine du soutien à l'industrie
de la défense alors que l' approche
intergouvernementale était auparavant la
règle la résolution européenne du sénat
que nous avons initié avec cyrille
pelegrin l'année dernière pour justement
donc être en phase avec l'actualité
prégnante fonds pour développer et
renforcer la base industrielle et
technologique de défense européenne
audap au diapason des autorités
françaises elle soutenait
financement ambitieux pour le fonds afin
qu'ils puissent exercer un véritable
effet de levier
hélas sous présidence finlandaise et
ensuite face à la crise sanitaire que
nous avons subi et que nous subissons
son enveloppe a été sérieusement juste
et à la baisse dans le cadre des
négociations sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel est l'instrument de relance
de 13 milliards d'euros dans les
propositions initiales de la commission
on est passé à un peu moins de 8
milliards d'euros en euros constants
même si nous comprenons bipeau ciation
comme celle du cadre financier
pluriannuel pensez vous monsieur le
ministre que ce niveau de crédit
traduisent un manque d'ambition des
états membres dans le domaine de
l'europe de la défense
nos partenaires européens partagent t-il
réellement l'ambition d'une véritable
autonomie stratégique européenne
pourriez vous nous éclairer sur les
rapports de force au sein du conseil en
la matière par ailleurs notre résolution
européenne souligné qu'au regard du
caractère stratégique de la recherche en
matière de défense
les états membres devraient être
étroitement associés au processus
décisionnel pour garantir que les
programmes financés par l'union
européennes répondent bien aux besoins
stratégiques de la politique de sécurité
et de défense commune et des états
membres considérez vous que le point
d'arrivée des négociations est
satisfaisant ce domaine la france a
soutenu le principe d'une répartition
1/3 2/3 entre les crédits destinés à la
recherche et ceux dédiés au
développement capacitaire pouvez vous
nous confirmer que cette répartition et
bien actée et nous préciser les premiers
projets qui seront financés par ce fonds
merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre au logement des propos de ma
collègue visuel jourda je me réjouis moi
aussi de la création de ce fonds
européens de la défense
même si comme elle serait tenté de dire
que les débuts nous inquiète un peu
puisqu'on est passé de 13 à 8 milliards
ce qui est au delà de la somme en
elle-même est une signification d'une
priorité qui mériterait peut-être d'être
confirmée conforter et vous pouvez
compter bien évidemment pour les raisons
qui viennent des dites par gisèle jourda
sur le soutien de notre commission des
affaires européennes dans dans le
prolongement de ces interrogations moi
je voudrais revenir sur la résolution
que nous avons adapté adoptée ici et
qu'ils puissent trait à la modalité de
mobilisation de ce fonds nous voulions
souligner que les destinataires et les
sous traitants participants un accent
financièrement soutenu par le fonds
devait être établi dans l'union
européenne ou dans un pays associés et
qu'il ne devait pas être soumis au
contrôle d'un pays tiers non associé
houdini une entité de pays tiers non
associés en août nous affirmions que les
infrastructures installations biens et
ressources de ses destinataires et sous
traitants devait être situés sur le
territoire d'un état mans ou d'un pays
associés pendant toute la durée de
l'action de même que leur structure
exécutive de gestion des dérogations
pouvait s'avérer nécessaire mais enfin
nous voulions affirmé ce point de vue
pouvez vous nous détailler le ministre
le contenu de l'accord final trouver le
14 décembre 2000 entre le conseil et le
parlement européen sur ces points le
communiqué du conseil indique que le
site
en principe le fait de fournir à des
incitations financières aux entités
établies dans l'union ou dans un pays
associés qui ne sont pas contrôlés par
un état tiers non associés ou une entité
d'un état tiers nos associés ça peut
paraître très technique mais derrière ça
quand même la question de notre
indépendance et de notre souveraineté
par conséquent la mobilisation de ce
fonds les modalités me paraissent aussi
importante que le principe même de la
création
ce n'est peut-être pas forcément ce que
peuvent partager l'ensemble des morts et
je pense notamment à l'estonie à la
pologne à la suède aux pays-bas la
bulgarie au danois et puis est ce que
vous auriez la possibilité d'autres
répondent nous dire deux mots ou de la
coopération en matière de défense avec
l'angleterre qui n'est plus piment mais
qui est quand même une armée comme la
nôtre qui est une cape avec une capacité
de projection et des caractéristiques
qui vire sans merci monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup
la sénatrice à monsieur le sénateur ça
me permet donc de revenir sur une des
avancées importantes de ce cadre
financier pluriannuel pour commencer par
la question budgétaire est importante et
derrière elle se cache où se pose la
question des ambitions partagées ou plus
ou moins partagé c'était votre question
dans la machine à trice des états
membres nous visions un peu plus de 10
milliards jusqu'à 13 nous avons fini à 7
milliards d'euros en euros constants 8
milliards d'euros en euros courants
donc c'est moins que nous l'aurions
souhaité
c'est évident mais je crois que il faut
le prendre comme une étape essentielle
pour être clair moi qui ai assisté aux
négociations budgétaires en détail je
peux vous dire que peu d'états en
faisait une priorité mais aucun état n'a
protesté le principe et je crois qu'il
faudra maintenant faire vivre le plus
vite possible
ce fonds et ses fonds ces financements
pour montrer leur utilité
donc là aussi c'est toujours une
question de verre à moitié plein de
marbre qui vide je pense que nous avons
fait en matière de la des flux en
matière de robes la défense et se font
européenne défense en témoignent les
avants c'est absolument crucial
ces 4 ou 5 dernières années dans un
domaine vous le savez
comme moi qui a été tabou pendant
extrêmement et si je reprends les trois
axes que le président avait mis en avant
dans son discours de la sorbonne en
matière de défense européenne
il y à presque quatre ans le capacitaire
le budgétaire le pilier budgétaire
pardon le pilier stratégique et le
pilier politique ou d'intervention nous
avons dansé chacun de ces domaines
maintenant un premier outil qui
fonctionne la coopération structurée
permanente initiatives européennes
d'intervention est désormais le fonds
européen de défense
je crois que c'est très important et que
je les dis sur la santé tout à l'heure
bâtissons sur cette première étape pour
montrer que ça marche nous avons mis
plus qu'un pied dans la porte
je pense que nous avons avant tout lever
le tabou de la défense européenne
et comme les épreuves rapin sur la santé
comme vous le rappeliez mais la
médiatrice l'appel des slogans c'est
pour ça que c'est aussi important
d'avoir ces outils je crois pas
aujourd'hui que nos principaux
partenaires
je pense à l'allemagne en particulier
donc d'ambition sur ce sujet nous
n'avons pas le même rapport alors de la
défense n'ont pas le même rapport à
l'autonomie stratégique c'est évident
nous n'avons pas le même rapport à nos
armées
nous voyons chaque jour mais regardez là
aussi sans être trop long ce qui s'est
passé avec l'engagement allemand à
l'extérieur y compris au sahel même si
c'est pas sur les mêmes missions que
nous d'évidence regarder l'engagement
que des pays qu'on aurait pu estimer
extrêmement loin de cette préoccupation
de sécurité de cet engagement militaire
je pense à l'estonie je pense à des pays
comme la suède comme la république
tchèque qui ont rejoint ce qu'on appelle
la force taku baltas force takouba de
forces spéciales
l'estonie qui envoient plus de 100
soldats en opération de front au mali
nous avons quand même un mouvement
européen en termes de prise de
responsabilité d'engagements financiers
désormais qui est très réel et donc je
je ne dis pas que c'est suffisant je ne
dis pas évidemment qu'on doit s'arrêter
là mais nous avons là une sorte de deux
bouts continuum ou de boîte à outils
budgétaires stratégiques politiques qui
est très important maintenant nous avons
un nouveau contexte vous l'évoquiez dans
vos interventions marquée par deux
points principalement même peut-être 3
la nouvelle administration américaine le
braque site qui est intervenu et c'est
un point conjoncturelle mais qui sera
important la transition politique en
allemagne
nous sommes l'une des élections la
chancelière ce n'est pas un scoop que je
vous livre ne sera plus chancelière dans
quelques mois puisque elle annoncé
qu'elle ne se représenterait pas
probablement donc à la fin de l'année
nous aurons un gouvernement un nouveau
gouvernement allemand pousse à créer un
peu de turbulences et nous aurons un
conseil européen les 25 et 26 février où
la question à notre demande de la
défense sera réaborder est je crois sans
rentrer dans le détail
à cette occasion d'autant plus qu'il
s'agira d'une visioconférence que
l'enjeu central c'est de réaffirmer
notamment ce concept d'autonomie
stratégique et nous le portons entre la
france et l'allemagne ça a été l'objet
d'un conseil franco allemand de défense
et de sécurité
coprésidée par le président de la
république et la chancelière angela
merkel vendredi dernier nous aurons à
cette occasion la nécessité de
réaffirmer ses engagements européens car
il est toujours à rappeler ou à
conforter c'est très clair maintenant
sur les outils on al houthi du fonds
européen de france faisons les vivres la
répartition vous évoquez un tiers
recherche de tir capacités c'est celle
que nous avons porté et c'est celle qui
se trouve dans le compromis final du 14
décembre pour être tout à fait précis
sur ce point en terme de projet il ya
des projets qui font partie aussi de
notre action en faveur de défense
européenne depuis 2010 est qu'ils ne
sont pas tous à 27d projet industriel
franco-allemand vous le que vous les
connaissez vous en connaissez aussi
parfois les difficultés l'avion du futur
le char du futur j'allais dire nous le
savions très bien en commençant en 2010
est parce que c'était totalement
innovant les allemands avaient une
habitude de coopération en matière de
défense qui était en train de stries
allemande et les français avaient une
habitude de coopération avec les
britanniques
quand ou coopérions avec d'autres
partenaires nous avons fait le pari qui
je pense
je le dis sans galvauder le mot est
historique dans le sens où c'était une
nécessité absolue
un virage stratégique absolument
nécessaire alors que le break 6 2 se
profile est de construire des
coopérations industrielles militaires
avec quelle manière oui c'est difficile
oui c'est long où il y aura des tensions
wii aura des blocages il y en a eu
on les a levés à chaque fois avec le
bundestag notamment parce qu'il ya un
arrière-plan si je puis dire politique
culturelle qui n'est pas le même en
france et en allemagne des règles
militaires l'armée par allemande vous le
savez depuis l'armée parlementaire n'a
évidemment pas pour des raisons
historiques évidentes les mêmes
capacités d'engagement le même consensus
politique que nos armées françaises ne
s'agit pas de saper la capacité
d'engagement de l'armée française mais
de renforcer par l'europe la capacité à
acheter européen développer du matériel
militaire européen nous ne pouvons le
faire que si nous lançons une
coopération qui sera encore une fois
longue et difficile mais indispensable
avec l'allemagne ce fonds européen de
défense pour faire le lien parlons
j'accélère monsieur le président ce
fonds européen de défense il pourra
financer typiquement s'est pas encore
décidée mais des projets bilatéraux du
type skaff ou du type charges du futur
qui d'ailleurs associe déjà certains
autres pays européens l'espagne vous le
savez notamment pour l'avion du futur
pour être le plus concret possible je
vous donne plus que ma science à ce
stade les premiers projets du fonds
européen de défense seront font l'objet
d'appels à projets et d'une sélection à
l'appel à projets parlant de 2021 et
d'une sélection est probable en deux
premiers décaissements au cours du
premier semestre 2022 sous présidence
française de l'union européenne il nous
appartient aussi au delà de ces
coopérations spécifiques que j'ai
évoquée avec l'allemagne de présenter
d'autres projets la france est
évidemment bien placé puisque nous avons
des projets en cours
capacitaires et de recherche qui peuvent
faire l'objet du financement européen ce
sera certainement une des politiques je
raisonne de manière un peu budgétaire de
nouveaux outils européens sur lesquels
nous aurons des meilleurs taux de retour
parce que nous sommes évidemment bien
placé deux points pardon jeu s'accélère
puisque vous avez soulevé la question
l'association d'états tiers
vous le savez ça a été un sujet de
difficultés et de négociations entre
états membres nous avons cette solution
qui est je le pense protectrice de
réserver les projets il faut qu'il ya
chaque fois trois entités de pays
différents et de réserver les projets
à des entités issues de pays membres de
l'union européenne évidemment ou de pays
associé de l'association européenne de
libre échange ce qui couvre par exemple
un pays comme la norvège mais pas le
royaume uni et je crois que c'est normal
à ce stade que nous n'ayons pas ouvert
davantage
c'était la demande de certains autres
qui ne visait pas seulement au royaume
uni mais parfois des grandes puissances
lointaine d'élargir davantage le
financement si on parle d'autonomie
stratégiques européennes et le
préférence européenne
ce fonds devrait être réservé à ces pays
là c'est très important et nous y
veillerons et nous pourrons avoir mais
c'est un deuxième temps et un second
débat une discussion ça renvoie aussi à
la question de ludovic elles ne pourront
avoir une discussion et au royaume-uni
ça n'a pas été leur souhait dans la
négociation de l'accord post corexit
mais c'est un sujet qui est devant nous
pour le fonds européen de défense comme
pour d'autres objets pour avoir des
coopérations spécifiques avec le royaume
uni
donc je ne préjuge pas de ce qui sera
décidé je crois qu'il faut être ouvert
mais en tout état de cause si par
exemple spéculation mais si par exemple
ils souhaitaient bénéficier d'outils
budgétaire européen ça ne pourrait se
faire qu'en échange de contributions et
en respectant nos règles de décision
s'agit pas de faire ce qu'on avait
appelé à l'époque de négociation et du
bric site sous l'égide de michel barnier
en anglais dit cherry picking de
l'europe à la carte dans laquelle il
aurait les avantages sans avoir les
obligations voilà pour être le plus
clair possible sur pays tiers royaume
uni la répartition et les prochaines
étapes
merci monsieur le ministre désolé de
vous presser un mais voilà il ya
beaucoup de sujets c'est vrai que c'est
dense alors on va passer au deuxième
sujet qui est l'évaluation des
technologies de santé donc ces mesdames
bruni est arrivée
je crois que madame marie b à
l'impératif arroseurs donc tu peux y
aller en étant visio ça marche
oui bonjour bonjour l'ours
ouais du côté on va revenir sur sur la
question de l'europe de la santé vous
disiez qu'il fallait pas que ce soit un
slogan en effet et on voit beaucoup de
choses qui se développe à l'heure
actuelle et d'ailleurs on pourrait
presque faire un parallèle avec avec la
défense parce qu'il se trouve que la
santé c'est quand même un un sujet de
une compétence d'appui et n'ont pas de
compétences partagées donc quelquefois
ça pose un problème parce qu'on est
souvent à la frontière delà de la
compétence partagée de la compétence
d'appui donc nous avions pris une
résolution au sujet des technologies de
la santé et ont demandé notamment que
les conditions relatives à la qualité à
la transparence à l'indépendance des
évaluations cliniques soient définies
dans le règlement parce que il ya un
règlement était en préparation et le
problème de la commission s'est que très
souvent elles renvoient à des actes
délégués la définition d'éléments qui
sont pourtant essentiels d'une
hésitation et comme on est dans une
compétence d'appuyer pas dans une
compétence partagée
c'est important que les choses soient
précises et au niveau du règlement et
non pas renvoyer aux actes de règlement
est très récemment s'est de nouveau nous
voulons interroger avec une nouvelle
résolution au sujet des trois règlements
en cours sur l' agence du médicament le
centre de prévention du contrôle des
maladies et les menaces
transfrontalières sur la santé donc
voilà qu'en est il des négociations sur
sur 7
sur cette question je remercie
infiniment merci pascal situé en ligne
oui je suis toujours là alors donc dans
le prolongement de ce que vient de dire
ma collègue laurence harribey moi je
voulais parler des modalités de
remboursement des technologies de santé
dont la définition relève de la
compétence des états membres et dans sa
résolution du 25 juin dernier le sénat
demandé que les états membres prennent
en compte les évaluations cliniques
commune réalisée à l'échelle de l'union
et qu'il soit autorisé à effectuer des
évaluations cliniques complémentaires
s'ils l'estiment nécessaire parce que
les résultats des évaluations cliniques
comines
elles ne peuvent pas être
obligatoirement reprises par les états
membres
et derrière c'est la politique de
remboursement de cette technologie de
santé qui doit rester pour nous du
ressort des états membres donc vouler
savoir on en était sûrs sur ces
discussions et ma collègue a aussi parlé
des trois propositions de règlement 727
726 725 et sur sur ces propositions on a
on a mis des avis motivés qui surtout
sur l'inquiétude que nous avons sur sur
la compétence qui doit rester en fait en
matière de santé aux états aux états
membres et non pas arrivé à même si on
veut des partenariats un peu plus
importants et des coordinations on veut
bien entendu de cette compétence elle
reste au niveau des états mans merci à
vous monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup pour ces questions
précises effectivement il y à une
négociation livre à une discussion
législative pardon européenne en cours
qui n'a pas abouti donc pas abouti ce
n'est pas négatif mais qu'il n'ait pas
été finalisé donc les sujets vous
évoquez sont encore ouverts est encore
en discussion vous aviez évoqué très tôt
cette crainte sur les procédures
d'évaluation pour qu'elle n'est pas
mais c'est triste grignote particulier
le caractère contraignant
parce que en effet en découlent
derrière l'évaluation elle-même la
politique de remboursement qui relève et
doit relever de chaque état membre et
donc il faudrait pas que par cette
évolution
on est remis en cause notre politique
l'autonomie une politique de
remboursement et c'est une préoccupation
vous avez exprimé que l'assemblée
nationale avait d'ailleurs soutenu que
plusieurs parlements nationaux ont
également ont également soulevé
notamment le parlement allemand le
parlement polonais est donc aujourd'hui
l'état les lieux c'est encore en état
des lieux provisoire c'est qu'au conseil
il y à un consensus qui semble se
dégager sur le refus d'une évaluation
contraignante et sur le maintien de
cette subsidiarité nécessaire pour que
nos politiques de remboursement en
france comme ailleurs ne soient pas
remises en cause des clauses puissions
procéder à nos propres évaluations
complément d'évaluation pour déterminer
ensuite nos politiques de remboursement
donc je je suis prudent je vous
tiendrais bien sûr au courant mais nous
n'avons pas d'inquiétude à ce stade le
respect de votre position qui est celle
du gouvernement aussi sera à mon avis
assuré parce qu'elle a un large soutien
d'importants est un membre de nombreux
états membres au sein du conseil
mais que c'est un travail encore en
cours donc restons vigilants aucun
article n'a encore été fermées dans ce
règlement dans ce projet mais nous nous
sommes très vigilants sur ce point et
sur l'autre point que souligné la
sénatrice harribey c'est à dire le fait
que le texte législatif soit le plus
précis possible pour ne pas renvoyer des
éléments notamment de cette nature aussi
structurant à des actes délayé donc à un
pouvoir réglementaire entre guillemets
pour prendre la comparaison nationale
qui donnerait trop de trop de marge de
folles de manoeuvre à la commission
européenne car la confiance n'exclut pas
le contrôle
comme chacun sait donc voilà prêt très
court nous partageons votre vigilance je
suis optimiste sur le respect du point
de vous avez soulevés et pour reprendre
à ce que disaient aussi le prix n'aura
pas tout à l'heure je crois fortement à
l'heure bleue à santé mais concrètement
ça ne doit pas être un slogan ça doit
vouloir dire des choses ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas européenne is et pour le
coup toutes les politiques de santé
fonctionne absolument aucun sens c'est
mener quelques actions communes
structurantes qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui dont concentrons nous sur
celle ci l'acquisition de vaccins
d'acquisition de matériel médical dans
certains domaines d'harmonisation jetez
pas si tout à l'heure mais le certaines
données ce qu'on a vu au début de
l'épidémie nous ne savions pas compter
le nombre de cas de co vide de manière
harmonisée ou de décès ou de victimes
l'état de la pandémie de manière
harmonisée entre la france l'allemagne
l'espagne et d'autres pays européens ce
qui pose des sujets puisque nous sommes
tous dans des comparaisons quotidienne
sur le front sanitaires ou maximal ce
qui pourrait aussi des sujets de de
transparence et de comparabilité
européenne important donc voilà lors de
la santé oui sur des aspects qui sont
très importants à mener ensemble dont
les vaccins et pas sur des politiques de
remboursement ou la question qui était
connexes des évaluations voilà pour être
clair
[Musique]